Hello, this is Dr.
Eugene Petko, and today
I will continue the
second part of our
session on pathology
of bone and joints.
Today we'll talk about
fractures, osteomyelitis,
we will describe
the seronegative
spondioarthropathies,
Then we
will cover
fibrous dysplasia,
simple bone cysts and
aneurysmal bone cysts,
and we'll end with
a bone tumor's
overview, describing
the benign and malignant
tumors of both the
bone and the cartilage.
About fractures. By
definition, a fracture
is a loss of bone
integrity, and we have
several types of fractures.
we have for example
a simple fracture
this is characterized
by an overlying skin
which is intact the
compound fracture in
this case the bone
communicates with skin
surface commutated fracture
we have several
bone fragments the
fragmentation can be
severe in some cases in a
displaced fracture we
see the ends of bone at
the fracture side are
not aligned we also
have other steps of
fractures for example
stress fracture this
is slowly developing
fracture that follows
a period of increased
physical activity in which
the bone is subjected
to repetitive mechanical
loads then the
In this case,
this is seen only
partially to the
bone and is common in
infants when bones
are very soft.
And then we have the
so-called pathological
fracture, which involves
a weak bone which
has been affected by
an underlying process
such as a metastatic
or a primary tumor.
Now I would like to
cover very briefly
the mechanism of
fracture repair.
Repair of bone
involves a regulated
expression of
numerous genes.
However, one of
the most essential
steps is the formation
of a hematoma. So
immediately after the
fracture, the rupture
of blood vessel
results in a hematoma
which fills and surrounds
the area of injury.
This has a very
important role as it
provides a fibrin mesh
that seals the fracture,
provides framework
for inflammatory cells
influx, fibroblast
ingrowth, and capillary
proliferation, which
ultimately would
lead to a formation
of granulation tissue.
Also,
the granulated
platelet inflammatory
cells at this level
with reliefs PDGF,
TGF-beta, FGF, and
other growth factors.
This will activate in
concert osteoprogenitor
cells in periosteum,
medullary
cavity, and surrounding
soft tissue,
stimulating osteoclastic
and osteoblastic
activity. So, after
hematoma formation,
the next stage is
the formation of an
internal callus, or
a pro-callus, if you
want. This is an
uncalcified soft tissue
and provides some
anchorage, but not
structural rigidity
for weight-bearing.
There is also an external
callus and within
two weeks of injury,
activated osteoprogenitor
cells deposit
subperiosteal trabeculae,
a woven bone oriented
perpendicular to a
cortical actus and within
a medullary cavity.
In time, this transforms
the callus into
a bonic structure
reaching maximal girth
at the end of the
second or third week,
helping to stabilize
the fracture site.
Then on the top of
all this, we have
endochondral ossification,
which makes contiguous
network of bone and
newly deported bone
trabeculate in medulla
and beneath periosteum.
The fracture bone
ends are bridged with
progressive
mineralization, stiffness
and strength of callus
increases allowing
weight bearing which
is very important.
The healing process
is completed
by restoration of
medullary cavity.
However,
inadequate immobilization
allows movement
of the callus
interfering with normal
maturation, which
might cause a delayed
union or non-union.
If non-union persists,
the malformed callus
undergo cystic
degeneration, and the
luminal surface can become
lined by synovial-like
cells, creating false
joints or what we call
a pseudoarthrosis.
Osteomyelitis.
Osteomyelitis represents
inflammation of
bone and marrow,
secondary to bacterial,
viral, fungal, and
parasitic infection.
However, no
specific organism is
identified in nearly
50% of the patients.
However,
some pyogenic
bacteria and
microbacteria are
most commonly seen.
Pyogenic osteomyelitis.
This is a bacterial
infection in which
the organism may
reach the bone by
hematogenic spread,
by extension from
a contiguous site
or by direct
implantation, for
example after a
traumatic injury.
Staphylococcus aureus
is identified in
80 to 90 of these
patients. However,
Escherichia coli,
Pseudomonas and
Klebsiella are also
seen, especially in those
with genitourinary
tract infection.
Hemophilus influenzae
and Group B
Streptococci are
common in neonates. I
would also like to
highlight that those
with sickle cell
disease are predisposed
to a special form
of osteomyelitis
determined by
Salmonella infection.
Osteomyelitis begins
with an acute stage in
which bacteria
proliferate and recruit
neutrophils to the injury
site. Within 48 hours
there is necrosis of
bone cells and marrow.
Bacteria and
associated inflammatory
cells spread to reach
periosteum forming
a characteristic
subperiosteal abscess.
Subsequently there
is periosteal
lifting which
impair blood supply
and contributes
to necrosis.
As a result soft
tissue abscesses
might form after
periosteal rupture.
This leads to skin
as draining sinuses.
We see now a dead bone
or a sequestrum and
this structure can
crumble and release
fragments into the
sinus tract forming a so
-called clacca indicating
a chronic stage.
Chronic osteomyelitis
is seen in 5% to
25% of cases anyway
as inflammation
continues chronic
inflammatory cells are
recruited during the
first week and release
cytokines that
would stimulate bone
resorption fibrous tissue
growth and peripheral
deposition of
reactive bone this new
bone can form a living
shell or involucrum
around the vitalized
infected bone.
On X-ray we see a
lytic focus of bone
destruction surrounded
by sclerosis.
This photo represents
a resected femur
in a person with
draining osteomyelitis.
The drainage tract in
the serperiostal shell
of the viable new bone,
involucrum, reveals
inner native necrotic
cortex, sequestrum.
Seronegative
spondyloatropathies,
these are immune
-mediated reactions
triggered by T
-cell responses,
presumably against
undefined microbial
antigens that cross-react
with musculoskeletal
system components they
are a heterogeneous
group of disorders
characterized by
the absence of
rheumatoid factor there
are pathological changes
in the ligamentous
attachments rather
than in synovium there
is sacroiliac joint
involvement and
association with HLA
-B27 there is also bony
proliferation leading
to ankylosis the best
examples are
ankylosing spondylitis
infectious arthritis
and reactive arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis
it causes destruction
of articular
cartilage and bony
ankylosis especially
sacroiliac and vertebral
apophysial joints
between tuberosities
and processes
it presents as lower back
pain and spinal
immobility
during the second
and third decades of
life approximately 90
percent of patients
are HLA B27 positive
but the role of this
factor is unknown
infectious arthritis
it is caused by
microorganisms that
affect joints by
hematogenous spread.
The joints may
be also infected
by direct inoculation
or to contiguous
spread from soft
tissue abscesses
or a focus of
osteomyelitis.
Arthritis or Reiter's
syndrome. This is
a triad of arthritis,
non gonococcal
urethritis or cervicitis
and conjunctivitis.
It is a mono or
oligoarticular arthritis
which appears in
intestinal infections
with Salmonella,
Shigella or Campylobacter
and in ********
transmitted
infections with
Chlamydia trachomatis.
However,
it also can
happen after group
A streptococcal
infections.
As a seronegative
spondyloarthropathy,
laboratory analysis
will show that the
patient is rheumatoid
factor negative,
and oftentimes
HLA-B27 positive.
The patients are
young adults.
50% of patients have
recurrent arthritis,
tendinitis, and
lumbosacral pain.
If active disease
is present more
than six months,
then the patient
has chronic
reactive arthritis.
Anyway,
initially they
experienced acute onset
asymmetric
oligoarthritis, often in
lower extremities,
especially the
knee, with inflammatory
low back pain.
In some patients, you
might see inflammation
at inception of
Achilles tendon and
plantar fasciitis,
with heel swelling,
as well as
inflammation of digits,
joint stiffness,
and low back pain.
Also in these
patients, we might
see extra-articular
involvement,
such as conjunctivitis
and uveitis,
dysuria, pelvic pain,
urethritis,
balanitis, cervicitis,
mucosal ulcers,
skin rashes, and cardiac
valvular disease.
Lime arthritis
The agent of Lyme
arthritis is the
spirochety Borrelia
burgdorferi, transmitted
by Dyrtix or Ixodis
It is the leading
artropore bone disease
in the US, most
often seen in the
area of New England,
Mid-Atlantic States
and Upper Midwest
The classic Lyme disease
involves multiple
organ systems and has
three clinical phases
In the early
localized stage,
there is an initial
skin infection, followed
within days to weeks
by dissemination
of the organism to
other cutaneous sites,
cranial nerves, heart,
and meninges This
is called the early
disseminated stage
The untreated or the
late disseminated
disease is associated
with a migratory
arthritis, the so
-called Lyme arthritis,
which is seen
in 80% of cases
and develops months
after infection
and can last
weeks to months
However, arthritis
occurs in less than
10% of Borrelia
infections, as most
are treated and cured
at earlier stage
Usually large
joints of the knees,
shoulders, elbows and
ankles are involved
But the arthritis
is limited
to one or two
joints at a time
Apart from arthritis,
the rash is also
very important for
clinical diagnosis
Lime rash looks
like a bull's eye
with circles
around the middle
Most are round, red and
at least 2 inches across
The rash slowly
gets bigger over
several days It can
grow to above 10-12
inches It might feel
warm to the touch
and is usually not
itchy or painful
It can show up on
any part of the body
The biopsy of the
bull's iron rash reveals
spore superficial
and deep lymphocytic
infiltrate under
uninvolved epidermis
Sometimes there might
be some epidermal
and or dermal necrosis
However, an infected
synovium will show
chronic synovitis,
synoviocytes hyperplasia,
fibrin deposition,
mononuclear cell
infiltrates especially
CD4 T cells and
obliterative endarthritis
There is also an
accentuated and
congested microvascular
network For diagnosis
purposes, we use
the serology, which
detects the anti
-borrelia antibodies
Therapy consists in
antibiotics such as
doxycycline, amoxicycline,
or sephuroxime
axetil, which are
very active against
borrelia The therapy
in these cases
results in cure rates
of more than 90%
Fibrous dysplasia.
This is a benign
tumor in which all
components of normal
bone are present,
but they do not
differentiate into
mature structures.
It appears during
skeletal development and
results from various
somatic gain-of
-function mutations in
GNAS1. This gene encodes
the stimulatory
alpha subunit of Gs
resulting in constitutively
active Gs protein,
promoting cellular
proliferation and
inhibition of osteoblast
differentiation.
It is characterized
by intramedullary
lytic lesions which
may expand and
cause bowing and
cortical fining.
Histologically,
they are corvilinear
trabeculae of woven bone
surrounded by moderately
cellular fibroblastic
proliferation
without prominent
obstreoblastic *******.
Fibrous dysplasia
might cause
pain, swelling,
pathologic
fractures or severe
bone deformity
and comes with three
clinical forms.
Monostotic fibrous
dysplasia is
diagnosed in the
early adolescence. The
most common sites
are the femur,
tibia, ribs, jaw
bones and canvaryum.
Oftentimes is
asymptomatic and is
discovered
incidentally that can
cause pain,
discrepancies in limb
length and
pathologic fractures.
It is treated by curatage
but oftentimes
it comes back.
Poliostotic fibrous
dysplasia, it is
diagnosed at a slightly
earlier age and
might continue in
adulthood It might be
seen in the femur,
skull and tibia There
is craniofacial
involvement as well,
especially in
patients with moderate
to extensive
skeletal disease
It may be progressive
with crippling
deformities and
fractures It is treated
with B-phosphonates
to reduce severity of
bone pain Very rarely
it may transform
into a sarcoma McCune
-Albright syndrome
This is a precocious
****** development,
especially in girls Which
present with various
endocrinopathies Such
as hyperthyroidis,
pituitary adenomas that
secrete growth hormone
and primary adrenal
hyperplasia.
Fibrous dysplasia
is unilateral and
the patients present
also with skin
lesions, the so
-called cafe au lait
spots on the same
side of the body.
Now let's talk about
the simple bone
cysts or the
unicameral bone cyst.
This is an incidental
finding, it's
not a neoplasm.
It is a fluid-filled
lesion with fibrous
lining and generally
occurs during the
first 20 years of
life. It is found near
the growth plate of
long bones, commonly
reoccurs or disappears
with maturity.
If it's large, it
may fracture. The
aneurysmal bone
cysts. These are
multi-loculated,
blood-filled spaces.
All ages may be affected,
but most commonly
they are seen in the
adolescence, in the
femur, tibia, and
vertebral body. On X-ray,
they present as expansive,
well-circumscribed
lytic lesions with well
-defined margins Most
will show central lysis
and thin sclerotic
eggshell of reactive
bone at the periphery
The multiple blood
-filled cystic spaces
are separated by
thin, tan-white
septa composed of
plump spindle cells
multinucleated osteoclast
-like giant cells
and reactive woven bone
lined by osteoblasts
I would like to mention
that in about
70% of cases
chromosome 17P13
rearrangements are
present within the
plump spindle cells
these result from
the fusion of the
USPS6 coding region
with promoters
of genes highly
expressed in the
osteoblasts, for
example, CDH11.
The USPS encodes an
ubiquitin-specific
protease that regulates
the activity of
the transcription
factor NFKB, which
in turn regulates
expression of proteins
such as MMPs, matrix
metalloproteases,
that lead to cystic
bone resorption.
Anyway, these patients
will present with
localized pain and
swelling that might
result in a limp,
vertebral lesions,
and nerve compression.
It is benign but
locally aggressive.
Therapy is represented
by curatage
or excision, but
the recurrence
is between 10 to
50% of cases. Now
I would like to
mention very briefly
some essential
facts about the
ganglion and synovial
cysts. Ganglion
cysts. These are
small up to 1.5 cm,
nearly always
located near a
joint capsule
or tendon sheet.
They are common
around joints of
wrist and appear
as firm, fluctuant,
pea-sized
translucent nodules.
They develop due
to cystic or myxoid
connective tissue
degeneration
However, the cystic
wall lacks cell lining
They might be
multilocular, can enlarge
through coalescence
and degeneration of
the adjacent connective
tissue The synovial
cysts These represent
herniation of
synovium through a
joint capsule or a
massive *********** of
a bursa For example,
we have the popliteal
synovial cyst
or Baker cyst,
which is associated with
rheumatoid arthritis.
The cyst lining,
in this case,
resembles synovium,
but both cyst
and synovium may
be hyperplastic.
The cyst fluid has
often an inflammatory
cell component as
well as fibrin.
primary bone tumors.
These are rare
and are outnumbered
by metastasis.
Most occur in long
bones of extremities.
I would like to
highlight that the
benign bone tumors are
oftentimes asymptomatic
and are identified
incidentally.
However, some are painful
and may cause
slow growing
masses or may produce a
pathological fracture.
The most important
factors in determining
the type of bone
tumor are the clinical
presentation,
radiographic appearance,
age of patient,
location of
lesion and
microscopic appearance
They mostly occur
during the first three
decades of life,
during the ages of
the greatest skeletal
growth activity
The distal femur
and the proximal
tibia, bones with
the highest growth
of rate, are the
most common sites
They might have
some specific
radiographic
presentations However,
the benign tumors
are much more
common than the
malignant tumors
Age is probably
the most important
clinical clue
to diagnosis
And I would like to
highlight that the
painful lesions almost
all the time are
associated with a
malignant aggressive tumor.
Now I would like to
talk very briefly
about two of the most
common benign tumors,
the osteoid osteoma
and osteoblastoma.
Both are bone
-producing lesions,
they have similar
histological
features but
different sizes,
different sites
of origin and
symptoms, but in both
cases the malignant
transformation
is very rare.
They are round to oval,
well circumscribed
masses of hemorrhagic
gritty tan tissue.
Microscopically you
You may see randomly
interconnected
trabeculae of woven bone
rimmed by single layer
of prominent osteoblast
surrounded by loose
connective tissue
with dilated and
congested capillaries.
A reactive bone
encircles the actual
neoplasm or nidus which
forms a small radiolucent
core that may be
centrally mineralized.
Osteoid osteoma is
treated by radiofrequency
ablation, while
osteoblastoma usually
requires curatage
or unblock excision
Osteoid osteoma,
by definition, is a
benign tumor of bone
with no malignant
potential It is less
than 2 cm in size
most commonly is
diagnosed in males younger
than 25 years and
arises in long bones
and on the surface
of facial bones or
skull it might be
associated with Gardner
syndrome Gardner
syndrome is seen in
patients with familial
adenomatous polyposis
and osteomas and
soft tissue tumors.
Osteodeosteomas are
slow-blowing lesions,
usually with no
clinical significance,
unless they
cause obstruction
or cosmetic issues.
However, some
patients might present
with nocturnal bone
pain, secondary
to excess
prostaglandin E2,
produced by proliferating
osteoblasts.
This is relieved by
aspirin and NSAIDs.
Clinically, a
thick rim of
reactive cortical
bone might be the
only investigational
finding.
Osteoblastoma. By
definition, these
lesions are larger
than 2 cm in size.
also these are seen
more commonly in
males younger than
25 years of age often
they arise in spine
but the patients
present with pain
which is not nocturnal
and the pain is not
relieved by aspirin
or other NSAIDs as
in osteoidosteoma
Osteochondroma or
exostosis. This is a very
common benign tumor
which is attached to
a skeleton by a bony
stalk cap bicartilage.
About 85% are solitary
and sporadic and the
reminder are part of
the autosomal dominant
multiple hereditary
exostosis syndrome.
Solitary osteochondromas
are usually
diagnosed in late
adolescence, early adulthood
Men are affected three
times more than women
Many are detected
incidentally
Osteochondromas develop
only in bones of
endochondral origin and
the most common site
is represented by the
metaphysis near the
growth plate of long
tubular bones, especially
near knee, and they
might be palpable.
However, they are slow
-growing masses and
can be painful if
impinged on a nerve.
Also, as you can
see in the attached
microscopic photo, they
are sysile or pedunculated
and range in size
from 1 to 20 cm.
Histology shows a
disorganized growth plate
which undergoes
endochondral ossification
There is a cartilaginous
cap lined by
perichondrium, contiguous
with mature bone
Chondroma or enchondroma
This is a benign
tumor of hyaline
cartilage arising within
medullary cavity in
which case we call
this enchondroma, or
on the bone surface,
in which case we
diagnose a juxtacortical
chondroma. The patients
are 20 to 50 years
of age. Usually they
are asymptomatic
and the lesions are
detected incidentally.
In some patients,
the lesion is painful
and might cause
pathological fractures
anyway the chondromas
are well circumscribed
nodules usually less
than 3 centimeters
and on the cut surface
they appear gray
-blue and translucent
they are characterized
by heterozygous
mutations in IDH1 and
IDH2 genes the histology
shows hypocellular
lesion with an
abundance of hyaline
cartilage. The
chondrocytes appear normal.
Also,
a peripheral endochondral
ossification
may be noted.
X-ray shows a
circumscribed lucency
with central irregular
calcifications,
sclerotic rim and
intact cortex.
Treatment usually is
observation or curatage.
Solitary chondromas
rarely undergo
sarcomatous
transformation,
but those lesions seen
in Ollier's disease
and Mafuci syndrome
do so more frequently.
Ollier's disease
and Mafuci syndrome
are non-hereditary
disorders
characterized by
multiple enchondromas.
Ollier's disease
is characterized by
enchondromas predominantly
confined to one
side of the body and
limited to the limbs.
There is an
increased risk of
chondrosarcoma
occurring later in life.
The risk has been
reported to be
up to 25-30% at
40 years of age.
Additionally, there
is an increased risk
of developing gliomas,
pancreatic and
juvenile granulosa cell
tumour of the ovary.
Mafucci syndrome
is characterized
by by multiple
enchondromas
and spindle
cell hemangiomas
The patients are at
risk of developing
other malignancies
including brain gliomas
The giant cell tumor
or osteoclastoma
This is a rare
benign tumor of
multinucleated osteoclast
type giant cells
This lesion can be
locally aggressive
and although it's
benign up to 4% of these
lesions metastasized
to the lungs however
they might regress
spontaneously
anyway the giant cell
tumors are rarely fatal
the majority are
seen near the knee
involving distal femur
or proximal tibia
they might cause
arthritis like symptoms
or the patient may
present with pathologic
fractures often
they destroy the
overlying cortex
resulting in bulging soft
tissue mass microscopically
these are large
red-brown masses that
frequently undergo
cystic degeneration
the histology shows
uniform oval mononuclear
tumor cells and
abundant osteoclast
type giant cells
with more than a
hundredth of nuclei each.
Also necrosis and mitotic
activity might
be prominent.
On X-ray there is the so
-called soap
bubble appearance.
It is treated by
curatage but 40 to
60% of cases might
recur locally.
Osteosarcoma
represents the most
common primary
malignant tumor of bone,
accounting for
approximately
20% of all bone cancers.
It has a bimodal
age distribution.
75% of cases occur
before 20 years of age.
There's a smaller
peak in older adults,
usually associated
with predisposing
conditions such
as pages disease,
bone infarcts or
prior radiation.
Men are affected
slightly more
often than
women 1.6 to 1.
This lesion
usually arise in
metaphysial region
of long bones.
Almost 50% are
described near the knee
in the distal femur
or proximal tibia.
Osteosarcomas are
bulky, gritty,
gray-white tumors,
usually with
hemorrhage and
cystic degeneration.
They often destroy the
surrounding cortices
to produce soft tissue
masses, spreading
extensively into
the medullary canal
and replacing the
hematopoietic marrow
histology reveals
pleomorphism large
hypochromatic nuclei
bizarre tumor giant
cells and abundant
mitosis including
abnormal triporal forms
there is extensive
necrosis and
intravascular invasion
Diagnosis requires
the presence of
malignant tumor
cells producing
unmineralized osteoid
or mineralized bone.
All osteosarcoma
patients are
assumed to have
occult metastasis
at the time of diagnosis.
Osteosarcoma metastasizes
hematogenously to
the lungs, bones,
brain, and other sites.
The five-year survival
rate is less than
20% in those with
metastasis, recurrent
disease, or secondary
osteosarcoma.
The microscopic image
on the left side
shows an osteosarcoma
of the proximal tibia.
There is a tan
white tumor filling
most of the medullary
cavity of the
metaphysis and
proximal diaphysis.
It has infiltrated
through the cortex. It
has lifted the periosteum
and has formed soft
tissue masses on both
sides of the bone.
The microscopic image
of the osteosarcoma
presented here
shows a fine lace
-like pattern of
neoplastic bone produced
by anaplastic
malignant tumor cells.
You can also see
abnormal mitosis.
Patients present
with pain, sometimes
due to pathologic
fractures.
The peak incidence
of osteosarcoma is
described during the
adolescent growth spurt.
Osteosarcoma occurs
most frequently
in the growth
plate of rapidly
growing bones, as
increased proliferation
may predispose
to mutations.
Approximately 7
% of the patients
have acquired genetic
abnormalities,
including chromosomal
aberrations.
Usually associated
mutations are
RB mutations.
These are
described in 75% of
sporadic
osteosarcoma cases.
Germline mutation of
TP53 in individuals
with Lee-Fraumeni
syndrome.
These patients present
with sarcoma and
or osteosarcoma,
breast, brain, and
adrenal cancer,
CDKN2A mutations.
This gene encodes two
tumor suppressors,
P16 and P14, and
these two are
inactivated in many
osteosarcomas. An
X-ray of the
osteosarcoma will show
a destructive mixed
lytic emblastic
mass with
infiltrative margins.
Often, it breaks
through the cortex and
lifts the periosteum,
inducing a reactive
periosteal bone formation.
We can distinguish
either a sunburst
pattern with stretched
out bone fibers from
rapid growth or a
triangular shadow between
the cortex and the
raised periostal ends
the so-called Cotman
triangle which indicates
an aggressive tumor
Ewing sarcoma This
is a malignant
bone tumor with
primitive round
cells without
differentiation
It represents 6-10%
of primary malignant
bone tumors being
the second most
common group of
pediatric bone sarcomas
Approximately 80
% of patients are
younger than 20
years of age Boys are
affected slightly
more than girls and
there is a predilection
for Caucasians
Individuals of
African or Asian
descent rarely
are affected
Usually it is seen
in the diaphysis of
long tubular bones,
especially femur
and flat bones of
pelvis But also is
seen in the humerus
and the ribs, and
presents as painful
enlarging masses
The affected site is
frequently tender, warm
and swollen There might
be systemic findings
that mimic infection,
including fever,
an elevated ESR,
anemia, and leucocytosis
An X-ray would reveal
a destructive lytic
tumor with permeative
or MOF-eaten margins
that extend into the
surrounding soft tissues
There is a
characteristic periosteal
reaction produced by
layers of reactive
bone deposited in an
onion skin fashion
In more than 90% of
Ewing sarcoma cases
there is a balanced
translocation
involving the EWSR1
gene on chromosome 22
and FLI1 gene on
chromosome 11, creating
the EWSR1-FLI1
fusion gene, encoding
for a chimeric
protein that binds to
chromatin and dysregulates
transcription,
leading to
uncontrolled growth
and abnormal
differentiation.
The cell of origin
of Ewing sarcoma
is not certain, but
mesenchymal stem
cells and primitive
neuroectodermal
cells are the most
likely candidates.
It usually arises
in the medullary
cavity and invades
the cortex,
periosteum, and
the soft tissue.
It presents as a
soft tan white mass
with areas of
hemorrhage and necrosis.
Histology reveals
sheets of uniform,
small round cells
with scant cytoplasm.
The cells form the so
-called Homer Wright
rosettes, rounded
cells displayed in
clusters with a
central fibrillary core
indicating a
neorectodermal
differentiation.
Dioxancomas are
aggressive and are
treated by neoadjuvant
chemotherapy
followed by
surgical excision if
possible and
adjuvant chemotherapy
with or without
irradiation.
This protocol has
achieved a 75%
five-year survival and a
50% long-term cure rates
Chondrosarcomas.
These lesions present
as painful
progressive enlarging
masses These are
malignant, cartilage
-producing tumors,
subclassified
histologically as
conventional, clear-cell,
dead-differentiated and
mesenchymal variants
Usually the patients
are in their 40s or
older, men are twice
more affected than women
These lesions are
commonly seen in
the axial skeleton,
especially the
pelvis, shoulder and
the ribs On X-ray,
achondrosarcoma
appears as foci of
calcified flocculant
densities Traditional
achondrosarcomas
are large, bulky
tumors made up of
nodules of glistening
gray-white translucent
cartilage The
matrix is often
gelatinous or mixed
weight and can
ooze on cut surface
There are sporty
calcifications
Central necrosis may
also create cystic spaces
Histology reveals
neoplastic cartilage
which infiltrates
the marrow space.
It surrounds bony
trabeculi and
vary in cellularity,
pleomorphism,
degree of cytologic
atipia, and mitotic
activity and are
graded from 1 to 3.
Histologic
grade correlates
directly with
biologic behavior.
Most conventional
chondrosarcomas
are grade 1 tumors.
These rarely
metastasize and have a
5-year survival
rate of 80% to 90%.
However, 70% of
grade 3 tumors spread
hematogenously to
the lungs and they
have a 5-year
survival rate of 43%.
Therapy is represented
by wide surgical
excision and or
adjuvant chemotherapy
Metastatic bone
tumors, these are much
more common than the
primary bone tumors
They spread to
the bone by direct
extension, via lymphatic
or hematogenous
dissemination And by
intraspinal seeding
In adults, more
than 75% of skeletal
metastases are coming
from the prostate,
breast, kidney,
and lung cancers
In children, the
metastases are
determined by
neuroblastoma, Wilms tumor,
osteosarcoma,
Ewing sarcoma, and
rhabdomyosarcoma They
are usually multifocal
On X-ray may be litig
or bone-destroying or
blastic bone-forming
Or mixed litig and
blastic For example,
prostatic
adenocarcinoma is
predominantly blastic
Carcinoma of a
kidney, lung and
gastrointestinal
tract And melanoma
are litig lesions
This image shows
breast cancer
metastasizing to a femur
with extension
through the
cortex into anterior
soft tissue.
I would like to
mention that there are
bidirectional interactions
between metastatic
cancer cells and the
native bone cells
that cause changes
in the bone matrix.
Tumor cells do not
directly resolve
bone in lytic lesions
but secrete substances
such as prostaglandins,
cytokines
and PTHRP that
upregulate rank ligand
on osteoblasts and
stromal cells. This
ultimately results
in stimulating
osteoclast activity
and bone resorption.
Tumor cells growth is
supported by release
of matrix-bound growth
factors such as TGF
-beta, IGF-1 and FGF
as bone is resorbed.
The presence of
bone metastasis
represents a poor
prognosis and the patients
are offered
symptomatic relief of
pain by analgesics
and radiotherapy.
It is also very important
to prevent further
spread of metastasis
in the skeleton.
This is done by
administration of
biphosphonates such
as zolendronic acid.